Then I suggest you suit up. Team.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie, this will be my Full Marvel
What If Season 2 Episode 2 video
There were a whole bunch of easter eggs and references
It's basically the 1980s Avengers.
Like, what have The Avengers formed
But in the late 1980s.
So the roster is different based on all the people
that were active around that period.
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
They'll be doing episodes one per day,
and obviously I'll be doing videos for everything.
So careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet, we'll start at the beginning, work
our way through, shop by shot,
talking about Easter eggs and WTF moments.
any of of the.
The episode was more about the Avengers forming
but in the 1980s the actual title was
What if Peter Quill attacked Earth's mightiest Heroes,
which is the tagline for The Avengers in the comics,
the whole idea is this is meant to take place
in the year 1988, about six months
after little kid Peter Quill was taken by Yondu
during the events of the first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie, He returns to Earth
because they're in the middle of ego.
The Living Planets
expansion plan during Guardians of the Galaxy two.
Like it's a bit of an amalgam plot
of some of the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
with Ego, the Living Planet, Peter Quill
and the formation of The Avengers.
There are a couple of things
that they changed about the way the ego's plan
works during Guardians of the Galaxy
two for the purposes of this episode.
during the episode
they explain he can't do it all simultaneously.
He can't activate all the seeds like
the infinity gantlet snapping his fingers.
he has to send Peter Quill or himself
around each planet one by one, activating the seeds,
the slow way, going the slow way around,
kind of like a reverse Thanos infinity gantlet plan.
perfectly balancing the universe,
turning them all into ego
in, when he's coming to Earth, he's already converted.
The rest of the nine realms, like Thor basically
explains later in the episode that Asgard R.I.P.
is no more, as are the rest of the nine realms.
Earth is like the last remaining one during the actual
opening scene, though, Peter Quill is flying
around the universe in the same type of celestial ship
that ego had during Guardians of the Galaxy two.
He's been sending Peter Quill,
like I said, all across the universe,
one planet at a time, activating these different seeds.
we hear Hayley Atwell as voice as Peggy Carter.
She came back to do her voice for the episode.
Pretty much all the actors from the movies
came back to voice their characters
in this episode I'll point them all out
when we get to their parts of the episode.
during this period in history,
Peggy Carter was busy running
Shield with Howard Stark at the Project Pegasus Base,
which is the same base
from the first Avenger movie,
just a more evolved version with better technology.
At that point, we also saw a version of the Pegasus
space during the first Captain Marvel movie.
It was where they were performing Project Pegasus,
which was that whole test ship.
Then trying to create a faster than light spaceship
using the tesseract,
so we're seeing a slightly older version
of Peggy Carter, but not quite as old
as she was during the flashback in the first Ant-Man
movie just before Howard Stark
was killed by the Winter Soldier,
which obviously goes down differently in this episode.
So Howard Stark
still alive in present day in this universe.
They explained that in this universe
pretty much everything is the same
as it was in the MCU up to this point.
So like all of the character
relationships are the same.
Everybody knows all the same things that they knew
when they knew them.
Inside the MCU.
their couple of quick shots around New York City
to show you that it is the eighties,
that there's like a lot of eighties culture, eighties
designs, eighties haircuts all over the place.
The song that plays here is out of control
by Love Affair, which is from the early eighties.
this song is also meant to be a metaphor
to Peter Quill ship literally being out of control,
He crashes right in front of Grand Central Station,
which is near
like full view of where the Avengers Tower
will eventually wind up inside the MCU.
But because the Avengers are forming much earlier
in the timeline here, we might not get
an actual Avengers tower, like they might build
their Avengers base somewhere completely different.
Eventually.
And you probably recognize this location
from many, many Marvel movies, particularly
the first Avengers movie
Peter Quill, also using his celestial powers to lift
all the cop cars is very similar to what Magneto did
in the original X-Men movie, lifting all the cop cars.
Ian McKellen also supposed to be coming back
as a version of Magneto, a different version
during Deadpool three, though,
we get a real quick blink and you'll miss it.
Cameo of the Watcher who actually appears on screen
in the skyline watching the events in this episode.
Unlike episode one,
I didn't spot him actually in the episode anywhere.
You only get his voiceover, I think during episode one.
part of the idea in Season one as well, too,
is that he would slowly
become more and more visible
with each successive episode.
so maybe the same situation in season two
where each episode you'll see just a little bit
more of him until he fully reveals himself
to all the other characters.
By the last couple of episodes
His voiceover at the beginning
here says that Peter Quill's hold turn in the episode.
The fact that he still misses his mother.
He wants to go home to Missouri,
where he came from, and he's just lonely.
they do the special What if intro scene.
And I've already done like a full Easter egg
and breakdown for all the different references here.
There are many, many of them in my episode one video
so opposed the link
for that in the description below,
But it's meant to be the exact same intro.
Is episode one Then the watcher explains where
this universe diverged in continuity from the main MCU.
Basically,
instead of raising Peter Quill himself, Yondu
ultimately took him to Ego the living planet,
wish he'd been hired to do in the first place?
they got into a lot of Yondu history
during Guardians of the Galaxy Volume two.
So the reason why Yondu got kicked off
his original Ravagers team,
his original team here in Star Hawks original team.
It's meant to be the actual Guardians
3000 team from the comics at the very first version
of the Guardians of the Galaxy team
that we saw in the comics.
they found out that Yondu had been trafficking
in children, so Starhawk kicked him off
of his Ravagers team.
that was why in present day,
everybody kind of hated his guts.
During Guardians two, So when you see all those bones
of the dead children that ego had killed on his planet.
Later in the movie, Yondu had been responsible
for bringing a lot of those children to him.
part of the idea, though, with Yondu is redemption,
is that when he eventually gets to Peter Quill, like,
he's like the next kid that he's hired to bring to ego
the living plan.
He doesn't want this little kid to get killed
like all the others.
So that's when he decides to go rogue
and raise him as his own.
but in this reality, in the episode that
never happened, he took him to ego the living planet.
He begins to set him on his mission
to absorb the universe by activating
the celestial seeds planet by plane.
And because Peter's much younger at this point in
history is way easier
for ego to manipulate him psychologically
and get him to do all these things.
You won't be needing these anymore, Peter.
Kurt Russell also
came back to do the voice of Ego
like he did during Guardians two.
He also voices Ego's Computer, which is kind of funny
because if you didn't realize this,
everything on Ego, the living Planet is literally
just an extension of his body.
So when he makes things like all the technology
that shows other pieces of him,
so when he's talking to the computer here, it's
kind of like ego just talking to himself.
Like the computer is just a part of ego, basically
Why can't I connect with my son?
According to his ships logs,
the vessel was compromised by an enemy combatant
That's why later in the episode,
he refers to them their army as we in
if it wasn't clear, even though you're seeing him
as a man here, like this is just a form
that he takes, it's
like a copy of the original version of ego.
The actual ego is that brain structure
at the center of ego, the living planet.
in his why at the end of the episode,
why Thor makes a reference to actually tracking down
Ego's Planet in destroying it
because that's how you perma kill ego
even though Peter Quill vaporized his body here,
that was just a copy of ego that he created.
he immediately
destroys Peter's Walkman and his mix tape.
His mother gave him like he did during Guardians two.
this is all meant to be sped up
versions of that original plot from the movies.
when he tosses him the ball,
that's also a reference to Guardians two.
They had a similar scene
and it's meant to be a joke about Peter finally
playing catch with his father,
which he'd been obsessed about like his entire life.
He'd always wanted
to have played catch with his father.
And now he's doing it.
during the next scene,
you see Peter Quill walking through the Brooklyn
Bridge, blowing stuff up
because he's on his way to Coney Island.
In the episode later, Bucky also sits on top of the
Brooklyn Bridge or looks out over the Brooklyn Bridge,
meant to be a reference to Captain America
in him going home because during the episode,
Bucky also starts to become good, starts his redemption
arc and basically goes rogue on Hydra
if he didn't remember, Steve Rogers
and Bucky are both from Brooklyn.
So it was like he was going home essentially.
They go back to the shield in space
from the Captain Marvel, the Avengers movie.
I don't think we saw this
control room during the Captain Marvel movie, though,
but this would have existed during that period.
Peggy Carter would have been doing the exact same thing
with Howard Stark
during the events of the Captain Marvel movie,
the whole wave of cosmic radiation consuming planets
nearby is a reference to Thor's story later about them
converting the rest of the nine realms.
R.I.P. Asgard.
then we see Howard Stark, and it is John Slattery
coming back to do the voice of the character.
He references a young Tony
Stark being a pain in the butt.
He be little older than hope, but
he's still a young teenager at this point in history,
like a couple of years younger than we saw him
during the Captain America Civil War.
Flashbacks.
Peggy Carter also reveals that she knows
Tony Stark and has met him before.
I guess he think of her as being kind of like
Aunt Peggy.
listen to what Aunt Peggy tells you to do.
any of that, they don't really get into it.
With a lot of the older Howard Stark scenes in the MCU.
Howard Stark is meant to be a genius inventor.
Just like Tony. He created Project Pegasus.
All the other projects they're working on,
like the Tesseract, faster than light Ship with marble
But he's not nearly as smart as Tony
Stark will be eventually.
But at this point in history,
young Tony Stark is still very much a ne'er do well.
then they reveal in this universe it's Peggy Carter
who comes up with the idea to form The Avengers.
But it's not till the end of the episode
that they come up with the name,
like we have to avenge the fallen,
so to speak, and play the Avengers theme song.
even though Nick Fury isn't in this episode,
he'd still be a Junior Shield agent at this point.
Working at the Project Pegasus Base.
He just had risen through the ranks quite as much yet.
And because in this episode,
everything changes, like history changes fundamentally.
At this point, they also probably means
that Carol Danvers never became
a version of Captain Marvel in the first place.
So the whole path to the creation
of the original Avengers in the MCU
later in the timeline is a completely different now,
even though some of the younger characters
now might still become versions of their future
superhero selves like Tony Stark
might still wind up becoming a version of Iron Man
just under different circumstances.
Howard Stark makes a bunch of eighties
references like MTV and We Are the World Song.
Everyone who was alive during the eighties
probably remembers that he makes
a couple of Cold War references
to set up Bucky in Winter Soldier stuff
because the Soviet Union still existed
until the early 1990s.
their 1980s Avengers
roster starts with Hank Pym, Ant-Man.
and because this episode is happening in 1988,
you have to remember
that Janet Van Dyne
got lost to the Quantum realm in 1987.
So she's only been gone for about a year, which is why
Hope has not been sent to boarding school yet.
this is meant to be his exact same house
from all the Ant-Man movies.
Michael Douglas
did come back to voice the character again.
He also did Hank Pym episodes during season one.
in it, the voice of Young Hope sounds familiar.
It's Madeleine McGraw doing The voice.
She's the same actress who played Young Hope during
those flashbacks in the Ant-Man and the WASP movie.
She's meant to be about the same age as Peter Quill.
for those of you asking, too, about Janet
Van Dyne in the quantum realm,
she didn't meet Kang the Conqueror for several years.
Like she had a full head of gray hair
when she met Kang.
So he hasn't crashed into the quantum realm yet.
They remind you that Hank Pym also hates Howard Stark,
blaming him for Janet
getting lost into the quantum realm.
But they put their differences aside because
celestial invasion world ending threatened all that.
when he tells Hope that he used to work here, it's
because he quit shield
right after Janet Van Dyne got lost in the quantum
realm.
Laurence Fishburne comes back to do the voice of Bill
Foster, Goliath, we actually see him in the Goliath
suit in Action is based on his comic book suit
to some of you probably recognize this, too.
They also brought back the live action
king to chalk actor
from the first Black Panther movie flashbacks
to play this version and really cool side
no really cool meta Easter
egg here to the person who was playing that live action
young king to Shaka is the real life
son of older king to Shaka he's wearing the exact
same song wearing during that first Black Panther movie
the flashback scene in that was in the nineties.
So he hasn't killed his brother yet
at this point in history.
Killmonger His father
But because it is 1988, T'Challa has already been born.
He was born in the early eighties.
He'd be about seven eight years old right now. sure.
He wasn't born to the late nineties,
so she isn't even close to being born yet.
They reference Howard Stark getting the vibranium
to make Captain America Shield as a gift
from two Shaka's father
when he was still king of Wakanda back during World
War Two, but losing it in the eyes
because the end of the first Captain America movie
went down the same way
this is also why Peggy Carter recognizes Bucky
as the Winter Soldier when he shows up freaking her
and Howard Stark out a little bit
because Howard Stark was there
and he met Bucky before he became the Winter Soldier.
in part of the idea is that, too.
Chaka also joins this eighties Avengers team, whereas
normally he be very isolationist
because world ending threat like celestial
show up on planet Earth
causes him to break from his former isolation his ways.
that also kind of implies that potentially Wakanda
would reveal itself to the world
much earlier in the timeline than they did in the MCU,
like at the end of the first Black Panther movie.
Imagine a version of that happening much sooner
in the timeline than we see Bucky as full winter
soldier like he starts the episode being in fall
Winter Soldier Hydra mode,
but over the course of the episode slowly begins
to break his programing, beginning his redemption arc.
By the end of the episode.
then we meet a younger version of Wendy Lawson, a.k.a.
Marvel, from the first Captain Marvel movie.
She's a female version of Marvel from the comics
her special ship
is the Tesseract prototype ship
from that first Captain Marvel movie.
The entire Pegasus space
was created for Project Pegasus, which was then trying
to create a faster than light ship
using the tesseract, the space stone And it is.
Annette Bening,
who came back to do the voice of the character.
one of the early differences here, too,
is that she fully reveals that right at the start here
that she is an alien.
Kree like, No, no, no, I'm not from the U.S. military.
probably one of the best parts of this episode, though,
is that all the different Avengers
actors here had great chemistry
with each other in the episode.
Like they would actually make a really solid Avengers
movie if you could somehow pull that off.
the they go to Coney Island to catch Peter Quill.
This is also where the final battle in Spider-Man
homecoming happened.
They also referenced it
during the first Captain America movie.
Hank Pym and Bill Foster joke about the 21 feet
limit that Bill Foster was able to achieve as Goliath.
But now he's way bigger.
They also did that during Ant-Man
and the WASP, just arguing about who could grow larger.
Hank Pym breaks out his army of ants on Peter Quill.
Kind of like what he did during Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantumania.
Marvel is also careful to tell Bucky
not to get the tesseract blown up.
Like, be careful, because if it does, Bob,
it would destroy the entire planet.
Then when Bill Foster saves her,
they actually played the Avengers theme song.
They play it a couple of times in the episode.
Do Then we get Thor joining the fight,
knocking Peter Quill out with a lightning blast.
It is Chris Hemsworth doing the voice
just like in season one, like he did all the Thor
roles in season one.
He also did Frog Thor in some cool
deleted scenes from the Loki series, too.
really hoping they would do like Frog Thor
or Alligator Loki during some what if episodes
I don't know if we're going to see them during season
two or season three.
We'll see.
they make it David Lee Roth Van Halen reference
because it is the 1980s.
Peter Quill is a fan of Van Halen.
the whole reason why they didn't go for the point break
joke again is because that movie
didn't come out until 1991.
So Peter literally has not seen it yet and wouldn't
know the reference when Thor also says that he is doom.
It also made me think of Doctor Doom
just because all this fantastic force stuff
that's happening right now and all these rumors
that Doctor Doom is going to be a big character
during Avengers Secret Wars and the live action movies.
Thor explains how celestial seeds work to them,
and why only other celestials can actually get close
to touching them.
Like Peter Quill ego, the living planet
who's like a rogue, celestial
or other regular celestials like erosion.
The judge always get a lot of questions
about this. Like ego.
The living planet seemed like he was different,
but he called himself a celestial
and the other celestial is during the eternals movie
seem like they operate a little bit differently,
like their technology was a little bit different.
So part of the idea is that ego is fundamentally
like the other celestials, like on a DNA kind of level.
But he's a rogue celestial,
so he's not part of the celestial host
and his abilities
just developed in a slightly different way as a result.
if you really think about it, his whole expansion
plan is kind of like a perverted version
of what the Celestials were doing in the Eternals movie
with their celestial seeds,
planting them all over the universe
but for very different purpose.
Then we get Hope's song and dance montage.
She's listening to Never Surrender
by Corey Hart on her Walkman,
which is just like Peter
Quill's Walkman that he lost to ego.
she uses that in the fact they both lost their mothers
to bond with him and it helps him escape.
she also winds up being the one
to convince the rest of the Avengers
to win him over like,
no, no, no, we don't need to kill him.
We need to help him.
notice here, too, that they're holding Peter in a cell.
That's pretty much the Hulk's cell
in the first Avengers movie.
Like, they developed it this early point
in the timeline and then just later repurposed it
for the Hulk.
Howard Stark makes another Tony Stark reference
when he jokes
about being a bad dad,
talking about ego, the living planet as a bad dad.
Like, Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hear about being a bad dad all the time for my son?
Robert Downey Jr has made all kinds of jokes
about Tony Stark's daddy issues, When hope calls ego
a space God, The Celestials aren't actual gods,
even though he calls himself like a little G God.
They're on the level of some gods,
like not all gods in the MCU.
Like people who are actually gods are created
equal For instance,
some are crazy powerful, like Odin,
who has the Odin force.
Some barely have any power at all,
There are also gods out there that haven't unlocked
their true potential yet, like Thor begins
to unlock his true potential in Thor Ragnarok.
Loki unlocks his true God level potential in Loki.
Season two.
they also reveal interesting detail.
The ego the living planet can communicate
with Peter psychically across the universe.
probably because of Peter's DNA
literally being half ego to chuck
a Black Panther gives them the idea to turn Peter
Quill against ego and have him take him down
using an ancient Will Condon proverb
that dates back before the first Black Panther
in the union of all their tribes.
they as you just announced that they're doing that
Black Panther animated
series later in 2024,
it's going to jump around in the timeline.
So we'll probably see other earlier
versions of Black Panther.
maybe during that we'll get a chance
to see the actual original Black Panther bashing.
Hank Pym basically wins over
Peter Quill by kind of adopting him in the episode,
like, please come be part of our actual family
with him and hope So it sounds like in this timeline,
he'll grow up as Hope's brother or like,
maybe they'll start a relationship with each other
when they get older.
Winter Soldier is also able to break his programing
after seeing their compassion
and hearing Howard Stark's appeals
and the memory of Steve Rogers.
Like all the Captain America name drops,
the the characters, a couple cool takedowns
and they're like a couple of new moves
they use for Thor like him using that concussive blast
when he returns the hammer to his hand.
the some of the best fights that they did, though,
during season one were at the end with Ultron
going up against the other characters
in that Thor versus Captain Marvel fight.
That was probably one of the best ones
Howard Stark makes a Terminator movie reference
when talking about Winter Soldier.
That movie came out in 1984,
so they don't price seen it several at this point.
and when Hank Perron takes Peter to ego
this whole exchange here where he turns against him
basically goes down the same way
it did in Guardians two just like a
sped up version where he reveals
he killed Peter's mother on purpose.
But there's one difference here.
When Peter absorbs the celestial seed
they explain that allows Peter
to keep his celestial powers
even though he kills this avatar of ego.
But the idea is that Peter's supposed
to have his celestial powers when ego's still alive
and the real ego is still alive
in the center of his planet
I think this whole seed idea is just a way to explain
how he can give himself a huge power upgrade
and keep his powers and be on this 1980s Avengers team
working with them
basically for the rest of his life even after
they eventually ultimately kill the real ego.
sort of like a hack that allows him to keep his powers
in the animated universe.
Here in the live action MCU,
Peter Quill does not have his celestial powers anymore.
They celebrate with beers. Back at Hank Pym house.
And it is weird that, too.
Chuck didn't know what light beer was like. T'Challa.
And sure, he claimed that he was a super fan
of American movies like Back to the Future.
So maybe that didn't happen too.
Like a little bit later in his life,
you think did he know about beer, though?
Because ancient Egypt had beer before
Wakanda became an actual thing?
We see Wendy giving goose
the cat to hope and Peter to keep.
They don't have any foreskin jokes, though.
You think they would have had a working joke
with the tongue coming out when Peter says
he's more of a dog guy, that's just a reference
to Cosmo, the talking space dog.
Bucky goes rogue, escaping
Hydra, looking out over the Brooklyn Bridge.
Like I said, he's meant to have gone home
because he is literally from Brooklyn.
they imply that he's going to start his redemption
arc much sooner in the timeline.
But Steve Rogers is still stuck in the ice right now.
are couple of jokes between all the characters
like to Shaka makes a joke about Thor
wearing his pajamas or sleeping in his armor.
When Thor says 53 gods, I think he's talking about all
the other asgardian gods from the Norse
mythology pantheon.
There are many, many of them in their pantheon, in Thor
basically sets up their Avengers
sequel movie with The Avengers officially forming.
When he says they're planning to track down
ego's the living planet,
kill the ego and avenge those that fallen.
they do their Guardians of the Galaxy Slow Team walk
but play the Avengers theme music
and they show Peter Quill's eyes
lighting up with celestial energy.
So they're trying to say that he's joining
the Avengers team, even though he is a little kid.
if you think about it now, too, in this reality,
because Winter Soldier turned good much sooner
in the timeline, that means he probably never wound up
killing Howard Stark or Maria.
Tony's parents
mean that if Iron Man grows up completely differently,
maybe if he does become Iron Man, the circumstances
would have to be completely different.
but part of the idea
with some of the younger characters like T'Challa,
who already exist, like he's been born,
he'll eventually take the mantle of Black Panther
and become part of this Avengers
team in some future roster.
some of the other characters like Hope, for instance,
who's with the team, isn't quite old enough
to start fighting with them, But at some point,
she'll eventually start wearing the WASP costume
and being official on the team.
one of the only things I don't think is happening,
though, is I think they're trying to say
that there will be no Carol
Danvers, Captain Marvel, in this universe.
like there's no way that that movie
would have gone down the same way
if The Avengers existed in the mid nineties
because they're in the 1980s right now.
So So by the time the Kree wind up showing up
many years later, the Avengers would have already
had many, many adventures under their belts
and been in their prime.
the only thing that I didn't spot in the episode,
they didn't really dress
is Peter's grandfather is still alive
and he still lives in Missouri.
Like he went to visit him
at the end of Guardians of the Galaxy three.
Like, I'm finally going back to Earth
to let my grandfather know that I've been alive
this whole time.
So if he's back on Earth now, living with hope
in Hank Pym, what happened to his grandfather?
Like, did they call him and tell him like,
you know, by the way, I'm back now and I'm alive,
but I'm living with this other family
Now, let me know in the comments.
How do you think they dealt with that plotline?
Like maybe Yondu just killed his grandfather
when he came to pick him up initially,
there are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references in the episode,
if you spotted any that
I didn't talk about in the video, just write them below
in the comments in my full episode
three video we'll post tomorrow.
That's going to be the
What if Happy Hogan Saved Christmas.
The big Die Hard episode should be pretty cool. does.
This is supposed to be a couple of big announcements
that Marvel will make later this week,
like they're supposed to announce
who's in that new Fantastic Four movie.
whatever they wind up revealing,
of course I'll do a video for it.
everyone click here for that.
For what if Season
two Episode three Video after the link.
As soon as I post that and click here for all my other.
What if episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!